is it domestic extremism for a parent to
advocate
for their child's best interests no i
would not describe as domestic extremism
is waiting to express one's view at a
school board meeting harassment and
intimidation as the attorney general's
memorandum made quite clear spirited
debate is welcome when and if
any
situation turns to violence
then that is the appropriate role of law
enforcement to address it you are
attempting to intimidate them you are
attempting to silence them you are
attempting to interfere with their
rights as parents and yes with their
rights as voters this is wrong this is
dangerous
let's bring in our panel see what they
think harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman and ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital molly hemingway senior
editor at the federalist and guy benson
political editor at townhall.com and
host of the guy benson show on fox news
radio great to see all of you i'll start
from the agreement point that i think we
all agree anything that crosses into
violence is unacceptable in many places
it's criminal and illegal but this is
what we're talking about now today from
the doj the memo says threats against
public servants are not only illegal
they run counter to our nation's core
values those who dedicate their time and
energy to ensuring that our children
receive a proper education and a safe
environment deserve to be able to do
their work without fear for their safety
molly what do you make of it it's just
amazing what the department of justice
and fbi will do and what they won't do
last year we had a series of violent
riots that cost two billion dollars
worth of damage killed dozens of people
attacked the white house federal
courthouses police precincts hundreds of
american businesses
and the department of justice and fbi
were basically nowhere to be found you
mentioned earlier tonight about how
little they did with the gymnast coach
who you had credible reports of him
raping people and fbi was nowhere to be
found and yet here when parents very
reasonably are concerned about all sorts
of things that have been happening in
their schools
whether it's teaching their students
teaching their own children to
to hate other people based on their race
or to think that they're victims who can
never succeed because of their race or
that the country is systematically
racist in a way that is irredeemable of
course parents are going to want to
weigh in on that and to intimidate them
and to declare war on american parents
particularly when the fbi and doj have
been nowhere to be found on issues where
they actually were needed is just
unconscionable a politicization of our
doj that is not tenable
so i want to play a little bit from a
board meeting one of these school board
meetings that we keep hearing so much
about and a little bit more of the
debate on this issue
there's no place for physical violence
anywhere for anyone but there's also no
place for intimidating parents from
speaking their mind and caring about
their kids education and their futures
justice should not be used to attack a
group of people expressing their
opinions at school board meetings that's
political speech that needs to be
protected
all right it's gotten heated harold but
do you worry that this may chill or be
an attempt to chill some parent speech
first thanks for having me on i hope it
doesn't chill anyone from sharing their
views we should all remember
that most school boards across the
country are elected there's some that
are that are controlled by city
government or the mayors of the county
executives in those areas but i think
the instances we're talking about here
are elected members of the school board
so we as voters have every right to vote
them out of office that's the ultimate
powerful expression of
whether we agree with or disagree with i
think we've now gotten to a very
delicate balance here and i would side
with molly on a lot of what she said and
disagree with some
whenever you threaten someone who's in
public office
whenever you try to exact violence on
someone to impose your political view
whether it's a view i agree with or
disagree with that's wrong and i think
what the justice department is trying to
achieve trying to achieve here is to say
that the violence and the threats are
wrong all of the dissent all of the
debate we should welcome that
whatever side of the wall you fall on on
any of these issues that are being
debated but i don't think any person be
they conservative or liberal be they
democrat or republican if they're an
elected official the way you really act
against an elected official is to vote
that person out of office not to
threaten them with violence or threaten
their family
with retribution
and meantime guy a lot of folks will
point to local ordinances state laws
that do
ban and and prohibit threats and
violence already they're on the books
yeah there's no place for violence
there's no place for threats there's no
place for going to someone's private
home or their family's home for example
there's no place for hounding or chasing
someone into a bathroom while filming
them to pick another example at complete
random there are certain bright lines in
our politics that should not be crossed
and if they are cross especially on the
criminal side i have no problem with law
enforcement getting involved
particularly at the local level i don't
understand why the federal government
and the department of justice and the
fbi needs to be involved in this
potential problem at all i feel like if
there are people issuing threats or
engage in violence that is something for
law enforcement to deal with of course
it's totally unacceptable and serious
what i worry about with the feds getting
involved in the attorney general from
this administration
sort of wading into this
is that this is an attempt to
delegitimize the legitimate complaints
that many parents have
with school boards with teachers unions
and others and to say well because there
might be some threats and some violence
elsewhere now this is a federal law
enforcement matter so you better you
know contain yourself restrain yourself
maybe think twice about showing up and
making your voice heard at a school
board meeting for example i think that
that is significant overreach
i want to touch on the facebook
whistleblower today as well play a
little bit of a little bit of the clips
from her today and then get a quick
comment from each of you
facebook's products harm children stoke
division and weaken our democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make facebook and instagram safer but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people kids who are bullied on
instagram
the bullying follows them home the last
thing they see before they go to bed at
night is someone being cruel to them
facebook is stuck in a feedback loop
that they cannot get out of they have
been hiding this information because
they feel trapped they need to admit
they did something wrong and they need
help to solve these problems and that's
what moral bankruptcy is
all right quickly we'll work our way
back guy then harold and molly
well look i think facebook has some real
serious questions to answer i think
oversight and accountability are both
appropriate ends here however i do have
some questions about how much of this
might be politically motivated and when
we start waiting into the misinformation
wars that's where i get a little bit
nervous
harold
this uh whistleblower her testimony was
plain spoken
stunningly compelling uh and frankly it
put puts facebook on it on its edges and
the other thing that facebook has to
worry about this is bipartisan that
entire committee republican and democrat
alike all sides with some not only
oversight but new regulations there's
every reason to be suspicious about this
this is a democratic information
operation it's being run by a democratic
pr firm and we already know that tech
companies have been colluding with the
democratic party to suppress
conservative speech and that's what's
happening here and people need to be on
guard about what they're being asked to
do in response to this alleged
whistleblower
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else